Mr Beast showed up to kill Tony last
week to give away $10,000 to the best
bucket pole of the night but the king of
YouTube surprising an arena full of
Comedy fans quickly went from an
unbelievable reveal to a super awkward
moment when everyone realized that there
was only one bucket pole worthy of the
$10,000 prize the man who is now only
referred to as split dick dad I feel
kind of bad cuz he was saying he was
living out of his car earlier he chose
the guy with the broken penis Mr Beast
being in attendance was not only a cool
milestone for the show but it also up
the panel to make some great jokes Mr
Beast what do you think of Janice's
performance I was more Curious how long
have you guys been dating 7 years 7 and
a half years seven wow o you guys
started dating in the year of the
[Laughter]
Rat Mr Beast how bad do you want to
bring water to her
Village